[Music]
amyotrophic lateral sclerosis shortened
to ALS is a neurodegenerative disease
which usually begins in adulthood and
advances rapidly it's characterized by
the deterioration and loss of both upper
and lower motor neurons as the motor
neurons stop sending signals the muscles
weaken leading to paralysis when the
muscles in the diaphragm are paralyzed
this can be fatal
there is no known cure for ALS for most
people the cause of their LS is unknown
but some people inherit the disease from
their parents by studying the genes that
are altered in these patients
scientists have pinpointed processes in
the neurons that might be causing ALS
it's too early to know which of these
altered processes are a result of the
disease and which could be a cause but
it's clear that they affect many
different aspects of the motor neuron
function let's start in the cell body
here proteins that are not transported
into the nucleus build up in the
cytoplasm errors in the systems that
build up and break down proteins also
cause other misfolded proteins to
accumulate the different proteins can
then aggregate and can become toxic to
cells in several ways for example they
can damage mitochondria the cell's power
generators mitochondrial damage can lead
to oxidative stress which can trigger
breaks in the DNA of the cell ALS seems
to affect DNA repair processes as well
when DNA breaks are poorly repaired it
ultimately contributes to the death of
the neuron the cells transport machinery
can also be damaged
for example ALS affected neurons often
have problems transporting RNA proteins
and vesicles both in the cytoplasm and
along the neurons axon these vesicles
containing pourtant cell signaling
molecules called neurotransmitters
if these can't be moved along the axon
or released the neuron can't send
messages to its target cells
damage to the cytoskeleton can also
cause the axon to retract if this
happens the axon can no longer connect
to the muscle nearby and can no longer
signal the muscle to contract other cell
types can also be involved in ALS
oligodendrocytes which electrically
insulate the axon and provide support to
the motor neuron don't work in people
with ALS reduced uptake of
neurotransmitters by astrocytes can lead
to over activation of the receptors at
the synapse and death of the neuron
finally astrocytes and microglia can
produce factors that protect or damaged
motor neurons neuronal death occurs when
excessive damaging factors are produced
further research is needed to find out
which of these many processes caused the
motor neuron degeneration seen in ALS
patients targeting new drug therapies at
those processes might lead to a
treatment for this incurable disease
[Music]